[Music]
jennifer is in fort lauderdale hi
jennifer how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i um i own a home here in fort
lauderdale and i owe about 292 000 on it
um you know the realtors keep saying i
can sell it for about 680.
the problem is i have 37 000 in debt i
have a bmw that i owe 20 and 17 000 and
credit card debt
i've got a guy saying let's just
refinance the house put the you know the
40 000 and mortgage 348 and i can tell
you 1200 a month and you can pay an
extra thousand dollars a month and get
it paid off in 10 years
the problem is i make over 150 000 but
it's like you know i get commission
checks so it's always hard to budget
correctly
you sell for a living room
are you a salesperson
yeah yeah i thought so
me too
because you sound just like i used to
sound i tried to out earn my stupidity
for years
and then i tried to borrow my way out of
it and you can't out earn it it catches
up doesn't it
you make 150 000 a year there's no
reason for you to have this debt except
you've just been lazy and disorganized
girl
i know
you don't need to refinance your home
thinking about selling it because moving
to the west coast by my parents and i'll
make you know 400 000 buy something cash
let me help you with this that's
treating the symptom
not the problem
okay the problem is you're not handling
money well i know
and i want you to do that for your sake
okay
hey i love you and i want you to win
but because i'm just like you that's why
i can read your mail i it's this exact
kind of stuff i did in my 20s that
caused me to be constantly broke
and um
so it
you know when you can get organized you
feel like you got a raise yeah
so what's the total amount of debt here
57
and you make 150 000 a year
this is an easy math equation
well no i have the 292 000 on the house
and i have 37 000 for the car and the
credit card back and 20 000 on the
credit card that's 57 000 plus your
house right
i have over 17 000 in my bank right now
that i could okay
yeah so we got to get you on a really
really tight budget where every single
dollar does one thing
reduce debt i mean let's pretend that
you
you really really really sacrificed and
you lived on only a hundred thousand for
one year
crimea river
and you took the other 50 000 of your
income and you became debt free
in one year
hello
are you there yeah she was so shocked
speechless is that was that sound was
that sound when you fell back on the
floor
and jennifer if you're following the
baby steps we teach you're not paying
off the house until baby steps six house
i don't i'm not worried about the house
your house is in great shape
you got a ton of equity in a great real
estate market now if you want to sell
super duper sell
but don't sell because you have a beamer
debt don't refinance because you have a
beamer debt due to your disorganization
and never having applied yourself to
this let me ask you this do you set
goals on your sales
yeah
there you go well we're talking about
game plan tonight dave and i've been
digging into this goal stuff and once
you put the numbers down and on paper
just your consumer debt not the mortgage
this is baby step two we're talking
about you're gonna have a thousand
dollars in savings the rest the 16 we're
throwing at the debt and we're going to
follow the debts almost all the credit
card debt's gone yeah and now the credit
cards never use them again
get on a written budget and let's reach
over there and knock that rest of those
credit cards out and then knock that
beamer out
and this beca what i'm telling you is it
becomes a goal when you set a goal in
sales you you say to yourself i gotta
kick it in gear i got a game on i got to
make it happen to hit this goal right
right but the only other problem is my
house i still need to put a new roof on
it and windows which is another 40 grand
you get what i mean so if you want to
sell your house 25 sell your house
but don't sell your house because you're
in debt
yeah okay you make a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year and we're
telling you how you can get out of debt
and if you want to sell it sell it i
don't care
i'm not but but don't refinance it and
don't sell it because you're in debt
because you're gonna go back in debt
because you never fixed why you went in
debt in the first place
and if you don't learn to save up the 40
000 to fix this house you're going to go
into debt for that too
and you know you have to stop this you
have to get the debt off the table and
say i'm sick and tired of constantly
paying the freaking bank i make too much
money to be this broke you have
seventeen thousand dollars to your name
and you make 150 grand
get disgusted girl
get mad not at yourself in a bad way but
get mad enough to change and say that's
it i've had it the worm has turned i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
whatever it is you have to yell up into
the clouds and say god help me i need
your help this is killing me yeah
and she's got a great shovel dave so
this is not a she makes a lot of money
she's a smart girl she can cashflow the
home repairs she can get out of his debt
and she could do it all in a year she if
she gets to selling so 97 fixes the
house and makes her debt free oh minus
16. so 81 does that making 150. so let's
just say we put 40 000 a year towards
this program in two years you're
debt-free and the house is repaired and
that's conservative
a year making 150 you are not applying z
principles this is what we do here
people
this is what we do you hang on girl
we're going to sign you up for financial
peace university if you will do what we
teach uh you're gonna be there in just a
matter of years if you don't
i predict you're still gonna be in the
mud
this is the ramsey show